okay it's 7 30. so uh good evening and
welcome members officers and member of
the public
uh to the uh
meeting of the Rochford District Council
uh planning a development committee on
this the 20th of July 2023
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is in the island
in front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meat team will be
live streamed please switch off mobiles
and or turn them to silent
and please note that toilet and hand
washing facilities are in the foyer area
members your voice will only be captured
on the live stream when your microphone
is switched on so please remember
to switch on your microphone when you
are invited to speak and switch off
again we're not speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands four
and then against recommendations and
will also ask for a show of hands for
those wishing to abstain from voting
Pretender items one and two apologies
for absence substitutes we have
apologies from Council award uh
councilor Foster is substituting
agenda item three non-members attending
councilor Gadsden
welcome
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 22nd of June 2023
are the minutes agreed members
thank you
agenda item five to receive Declarations
of Interest are there any Declarations
of interests please members
thank you chairman pecuniary interest in
the land east of Ashland Road discussion
as award counselor
thank you councilor Foster
one Parish councilor what's your Parish
thank you Council and the same as
counselor Ian Foster item six thank you
thank you
I see no others so I'll take that as
complete
[Applause]
agenda item six
uh
2230033 full land east of ashington Road
and North of Rochford Garden Way
um I was going to say if there were any
members of the public here that
obviously this is not something where we
are looking to change the permission
that has been given to build on the site
this is just a technical
um matter that goes along with the uh
the building out of the site
um
uh members there is additional
information on the addendum relating to
this application
Katie Rogers will present oh sorry
counselor sure
just one point chairman um on the first
page it says secondary success into onto
Percy cotton Cottage Road I think that
should be accessed
thank you
okay there's no dude thank you so uh
with that I'll hand over to Katie Rogers
who will presented the officer's report
thank you thank you
you can hear me yeah
okay
outpatient relates to the land edged red
on the plan on the screen and for the
benefit of those who find the red line
difficult to see
um I'll just go around it and the site
largely comprises a former agricultural
field with the western boundary running
um down the rear Gardens of property
existing properties on ashington road
the northern boundary runs um adjacent
the rear Garden of boundaries on Oxford
Road and the southern boundary runs
alongside existing property boundaries
on Rochford Garden Way Percy Cottage
Road and then a small section of the
drive in the Southeastern corner
so the site benefits from planning
permission granted on appeal last year
and the planning consent was a hybrid
consent with full planning permission
granted in relation to phase one and
outline planning permission with all
matters reserved apart from access and
layout relating to phases two and three
the plan on screen shows the proposed
phasing plan the approved phasing plan
with phase one areas of the site colored
this pinky sort of salmon color so this
area here this Slither here these bits
here and this part over to this side
so the phase one area included the res
this residential parcel in the
southwestern corner but also so this
East-West Stitch this is what we call
the central Northern Green Space and the
Eastern Parkland was also in phase one
where full planning permission was
granted
um they relate to strategic landscaped
areas at the site
no changes proposed to the approved
scheme relating to this phase one
residential parcel
the proposed changes tonight relate to
the layout of development within phase
two so the green area within phase three
um the blue area and also some changes
to the resident um phase one in respect
of the Strategic green spaces
particularly
um this Central Northern Green Space
here
So the plan on screen now is the
proposed layout plan which shows the
phases two and three so phase two is
this area south of the East West ditch
and phase three is this area this parcel
here and this bit here north of the East
West Stitch
it also shows these strategic green
spaces the central Northern Green Space
here the East-West ditch and the Eastern
Parkland here
so this layout plan proposes changes
compared to the approved layout of
phases two and three and these changes
are summarized on pages 6.23 and 6.24 of
the committee report and I'm going to
take you through some plan extracts to
compare the approved
um to the proposed
so the extracts I'm going to show
um oops sorry
um
are areas within this within this plan
here
So the plan extracts here show a
comparison of the approved layout in the
north west corner of the site
and the plan on the left hand side here
is a sec as an extract of the approved
layout and the plan on the right hand
side is an extract of the proposed
layout
the corner of the site borders existing
properties on ashendon road here to the
west and Oxford Road here to the north
So the plan sorry
you'll note that the road layout is
proposed to change
as approved a turning head was provided
at the south end after the road bent
round to the south in this part here
the road layout is now proposed to
include a t-junction at the end of that
street here
and as a result of the change to the
turning head the layout of dwellings
where the turning head had been cited is
now proposed to change so in this area
here
so where there had been a semi-detached
pair of properties there is now a
detached house and a semi-detached pair
so there was a pairs of samis here and
this has changed to a pair of some is
two pairs of semi-detached houses and a
detached property on the end
you'll note that in terms of the
sighting of the dwellings along the
northern so this area here and the
Western
edges in this part of the site very
little changes proposed compared to the
approved scheme The Proposal is still
showing two Terraces
so approved to Terraces and a
semi-detached pair here and on the
proposed layout you still have that
arrangement with the proposed Terraces
and the semi-detached pair in the middle
the two Maize net blocks here and here
are still proposed but the orientation
of this block which was at 90 degrees is
now in line so there's a minor change
there
in the bottom left hand corner of this
plan extract there was a detached house
if you can see my cursor on the left
hand side here at the bottom that was a
detached house whose side elevation ran
parallel in close proximity to the rear
Garden of that existing property on
ashington road and if you see on the
right hand side now you've got a
semi-detached pair orientated at a
different angle to that rear Garden
boundary with a slightly greater degree
of separation
I'll set out in the committee report
where changes are proposed to the
sighting of proposed houses adjacent the
site boundaries it is considered that
the proposed layout would be equally
acceptable in terms of impact on
residential amenity of existing
neighboring Residential Properties
some of the dwelling types are also
proposed to change I've already
mentioned a few on this plan extract
you'll note that where two detached
properties were proposed here so my
curse is on the left-hand plan we've now
got an additional pair of semi-detached
properties there
and there are other instances Across The
Wider phase two three layout where
similar changes to the dwelling type to
be provided and changes to the plot
shape or size for individual dwellings
is now proposed
so this is the second plan extract I've
got for you so these images show again
the approved layout on the left hand
side of the screen and the proposed
layout on the right hand side of the
screen and these properties
sorry in both cases we've just moved
slightly East from the previous extract
to show you we're still on the Northern
boundary of the site so this borders
properties on Oxford Road to the north
so the approved layout proposed two
areas of Green Space here
bisected by a road running East-West
approximately
and the proposed amended layout still
proposes two areas of green space but
the Northern Area so this part here is
now proposed to be slightly larger than
was approved and the southern area is
proposed to have a different shape
um wider but less deep
the True Green spaces would still be
bisected by a road but the road would
change in form and now would consist of
this s Bend
below to the proposed dwellings in the
area particularly so this was approved
this area to the east of the northern
Green Space is proposed to change
so the approved layout featured two
flooded blocks here and here
two rows of terraced houses here and
here just to the North and then there
was a a little sort of maisonet flooded
block attached to one of these Terraces
um to the to the left-hand side
so now we have a flooded block proposed
on this corner
this little cluster of Maisonette
properties a two-story
um and then we have this u-shaped
cluster of maisonettes in the northern
part of that section
Shad Surface Street is now proposed
between the two and this would lead to
this kind of central Northern Green
Space
a new flatted block is also proposed on
this corner here west of the northern
Green Space whereas you'll note on the
approved scheme we had a different
arrangement of dwellings proposed there
the central Northern Green Space would
continue to function as a public amenity
space with moment pass throughout so you
can see the moan past a slightly
different arrangement
um
and the hard surface paths would also be
provided so if you can see my cursor on
the right hand side a hard surface path
would run up here along the northern
boundary linking to that shared Surface
Street here and then this path would
also run down this side and link to the
foot way along the S Bend in the road
the northern part of the Green Space
would continue to function as part of
the flood alleviation scheme at the site
capturing surface water falling onto the
site during rainfall events and
transferring it to the ditch which will
run along the western edge that was the
same as the proposal in this scheme
and then the water will be transferred
to the ditch that runs East-West and
then eventually out falling off site by
the public sewer
these two plant extracts show the ditch
which runs across the site east to west
the approved plan extract is at the top
of the screen and the proposed amended
site layout plan extract is to the
bottom of the screen
on your note that three yellow arrows
are shown this one that Northern plan
you've got one here here and here
and then again on the proposed you've
got one here here and here
these indicate that three pedestrian
Crossings of the ditch remain proposed
and on the approved layout a footpath
was to be provided all the way along the
East-West Stitch but as approved part of
that footpath
um was on the southern boundary of that
ditch whereas this section to the west
and this section to the east were on the
North and one of the changes proposes
now that that footway runs consistently
along the northern part of that
East-West ditch
the East West Stitch would remain tree
lined and housing to be provided along
the ditch characterized still by a mix
of detached and semi-detached properties
these two plan extracts show a section
of the North Eastern corner of the site
bordering the rear Gardens of existing
properties on Oxford Road again so this
is the Far Eastern corner of Oxford Road
again the left-hand plan extract is a
section of the approved layout here and
the right hand side is the proposed
dwellings would continue to be cited
fronting onto the Eastern Parkland so
this in this area here that was approved
this is proposed
and these would all continue to be
detached these form part of what was
known as the green Fringe character area
and changes have been made to further
enhance the distinctiveness of this part
of the site some of the dwellings have
been given deeper front Gardens so these
ones here compared to what had been
approved and some of them have been
orientated at slight angles to one
another
the road in this section of the site has
also changed so this is now proposed as
a shared Surface Street
um compared to what was approved
on these plan extracts you'll also note
that the positions of some of the red
dots hopefully you can see those if you
can see the red dots here on the
approved plan and on these properties
here and that that Mason net pair on
that corner here
these denote affordable housing and some
of these have changed
while some changes are proposed in terms
of which plots will be provided as
affordable housing compared to the
approved
across the site the affordable housing
would still continue to be provided at
approximately the same location so what
we still didn't get is clusters of
affordable dotted across the The Wider
site as a whole
you'll note that no change is proposed
to
um these affordable houses here so you
on the approved layout we have these two
pairs of semi-detached and again you've
still got those proposed so it's
certainly not the case that all the
affordable housing is proposing to
change in terms of the location of them
so this final
um plan extract comparison shows a
section of the southern boundary of the
site so now we've got rear Gardens of
existing properties on Rochford Garden
way to the South
the layout and sighting of dwellings
proposed here is very similar to the uh
to the layout as approved and again this
approved layout is on the left hand side
of the screen and the proposed on the
right
however the street to run parallel to
the southern boundary to this one here
is now proposed again as a shared
Surface Street and some changes are
proposed to the sighting and dwelling
types proposed which would face this
attenuation Basin here to the east so we
had
um three detached properties and then a
detached property
um to the South here and now we've got a
sort of mix of semi-detached and
detached properties but still fronting
onto this um kind of open space
attenuation Basin to the east
so I just take you back the proposed
layout as a whole so there's extracts
are from this proposed layout and across
the site as a whole car parking
provision is proposed which would meet
the council's adopted parking standard
it is considered that the proposed
revised layout would be equally
acceptable in terms of design with some
additional benefits included in the
layout now for example the extension of
the cycle route so there was
um included within the original scheme
um areas of pavement essentially that
are wider to allow for a designated
cycle path alongside a footway and
there's just an additional section of
that now built into the layout and
that's where my cursor is here in the
sort of Southeastern corner
in terms of the mix of one two three and
four bed affordable houses to be
provided in phases two and three this
would remain almost exactly the same as
the approved scheme say for the fact
that too few or two bed affordable
houses and two more three bed affordable
homes would now be proposed this is set
out in the table in the committee report
at page 6.46 in total 148 affordable
homes would continue to be provided as
per the approved scheme in terms of
number across phases two and three
um the proposed changes again we
consider to be equally acceptable in
terms of design including changes to the
road layout and road type and the
recommendation therefore chairman is one
of approval subject to the recommended
conditions are set out in the committee
report and as reported on the addendum
thank you Katie there is one public
speaker on this item uh Mr Anna's Magda
planning agent Mr actor please take your
place at the microphone you have five
minutes to speak thank you
thank you thank you Chef my name is Anna
smakta I'm the planning agent for this
application acting on behalf of blow
homes
this is a planning application that
seeks to amend an approved layout
the scope of this application is to
consider the layout changes that are
proposed only as China at the top of
this meeting the principle of the
development is not open for
consideration as the site continues to
benefit from planning permission for new
homes
your offices report and the presentation
today provides a clear accounting of the
changes that are proposed and provides a
thorough assessment of the acceptability
of those changes
changes which have been agreed where
necessary in consultation with relevant
statistury Consultants
the amended scheme that is before you
today provides a package of improvements
that enhances the quality of the site
the amended layout has been designed to
improve the setting and street scene of
the homes the distinction and legibility
of the character areas connectivity and
permeability through the site as well as
provide a greater area of and better
designed public open space
these Amendments have all been designed
in closely liaison with your offices
and I would like to take this
opportunity to to thank your officers
for their cooperation and collaboration
throughout what's been a hugely involved
application process
the positive nature of the post amends
is exemplified by the Urban Design
officers consolation comments which
highlight the layout improvements that
will be achieved as a result of the
immense proposed by this application
members I will keep this brief as the
officer has clearly confirmed in detail
that there are no technical objections
to the Amendments which are proposed
the application complies with local and
National planning policy as well as the
guidance that is relevant to this type
of application
and therefore respectfully request that
you accept your office recommendation
for approval and approve this money
application
thank you
thank you Mr America please return to
your seat
questions
uh members please will allow everyone
the opportunity to speak
um however I will limit if necessary uh
you'll speak into five minutes
um are there any visiting members who
would like to speak
no
so Ward councilors First Ward councilors
would you like to comment in the future
thank you chairman
um yes I've got some observations and
questions if I may
uh first of all on page 6.13.31
um we've talked about contamination
with the contamination definition
include Japanese knotweed which Bloor
has agreed to arrange a further review
of the perimeter of the site after
resident concerns were raised we
discussed that as a meeting at the site
a couple of weeks ago
according to the report it also says
development would be halted if
contamination is found so my question is
is that correct and is would not we
count in that assessment of
contamination
on pages
6.16 and 6.17.46
this is an observation rather than a
question it says in there the reason for
the actions in the C EMP is described as
to ensure the environmental impact of
the construction of the development is
adequately mitigated and in the interest
of the amenity of nearby residents for
instance occupiers
um I have to say based on observations
of recent months that residents would
find it
any claim compliance with points 46 a b
D E J and M to be laughable frankly and
that's just a comment not a question
on page 6.19 0.6 C
could it be confirmed that the widening
of the junction works the completion of
the new Lane right turn lane and surface
works at the entry to the site would be
completed by the end of the halt Farm
Schools summer holidays originally um
people may recall that those Works will
propose at very start for reasons which
I think people understand they got
delayed
um on pages 6.23 6.24 which relate to
phases two and three as we've heard
um 1.3 on phase two talks about
amendments to location and mix
brackets bin numbers
um
of affordable homes so the question is
does this increase or decrease the
number of bed spaces in the affordable
homes
uh on 6.23
0.1.3 reference phase three
it mentions an additional flatted block
so my question is is this increasing the
number of total homes in the
whole development beyond the 662 that
are approved that may have already
mentioned I'm not sure
it also makes the same comment about
phase three is about the amendment to
location and mix brackets bed numbers of
affordable units so my same question as
phase two is does ink possess increase
or decrease the number of affordable bid
spaces
on page 6.35 2.69
describes a mix of apartment blocks and
Mason X
written 2.7 on page 6.35 includes a new
apartment block my question is again
this is a repeat in a sense do these
changes increase the total number in the
development 662 approved
on page 6.39 item 2.85 to 2.88
it makes changes which
amend some plots from being compliant
with guidance on distance from existing
property to making it less than Essex
design guide
why why should that be acceptable
on page six uh
0.40.2.88 2.89 and 290.
um
it mentions all moving houses closer to
existing houses
and again the question is why
on page 6.4 641 sorry 0.2.96
he said I quote residential buildings
would largely be capable of
accommodating the minimum amenity space
is that acceptable largely means not all
I think
I've been capable of accommodating the
minimum amenity space so is that
acceptable thank you
thank you to councilor Foster Katie
would you like to come back on those yes
thank you
um right that's only for order to go in
we'll go reverse order I think so
um in terms of
um the last Point Raise
Garden area compliance with your policy
so in paragraph 2.97 of page 6.41 it
does note that one plot is some 5.4
meters squared below the 100 square
meters that would be required
um for that particular plot but because
of its proximity to
um areas of Green Space to be provided
within the site we say that actually
does comply with the council's
supplementary planning guidance because
that that supplementary planning
guidance does quote the 100 square meter
figure but says to be taken into account
of
um the sighting of the property in its
relation to areas of public open Green
Space so that that's our viewers to why
that
um makes this proposed scheme revision
acceptable sorry for major so you're
saying largely it means everything
except more yes okay thank you
um 662 dwellings I can confirm that that
is the number proposed as was approved
so there's no change there
um in terms of your point in relation to
compliance distances with neighboring
properties I think you referred to
paragraph 2.88 sorry I didn't get what
page number that's on but if I'll take
you to
um this plan extract again oh 6.39 6.39
thank you
um
sorry not that one Central Northern
Green Space
okay
so what we are referring to here is if
you if I can take you to this area of
the site here so you can see there's an
arrangement of properties here with
existing properties on Oxford Road
um to the north
um and now we have an arrangement where
we've got some maisonettes
um and that relationship with existing
boundary of properties on Oxford Road to
the north
so we have to take into consideration
and bear in mind we are just assessing
access and layout so in terms of layout
it's the positioning of dwellings what
we don't have at this stage is the
elevations because that speaks to the
appearance of dwellings which will be
considered in a later Reserve matters
application
but in relation to the layout what the
Essex design guide
um
has within it is a distance of 35 meters
where you have a flat proposed rear wood
of an existing dwelling now the existing
dwelling is just off plan here but it's
approximately where my cursor is and
some of these dwellings on Oxford Road
have been extended okay so that makes
that distance between this elevation of
the property proposed and the rear rear
most elevation of that property on the
existing
um dwelling
um narrowed compared to what it was when
it was originally built so we've taken
into account the fact that some of these
have been extended and in one case in
relation to this property proposed here
that distance doesn't quite meet the 35
meters okay and that distance is about
ensuring rear privacy from new
development
but what we're comfortable with is that
distance is not so short that it's
seriously unreasonable so we're talking
about a few meters under that 35 meter
reference in the supplementary planning
guidance
and what we are able to do when a
reserve matters application comes before
us is ensure that the window openings at
first floor and we're really concerned
in a flat about main living spaces so
kitchens lounges where you'd probably
spend quite a lot of time and Outlook
quite a lot would need to be in this
elevation facing south okay and that's
within our control it's within your gift
as members determining any future
Reserve maths application
so we've looked carefully at the
relationship here but we're satisfied
that this layout
subject to
detailed consideration of the actual
three-dimensional building that's going
to be put there and the positioning of
windows will be an acceptable
relationship
um so that deals with that point there
um in terms of the number of bed spaces
in affordable dwellings so there is
slight change to the affordable mix
that's proposed in relation to phases
both I'll go back to the proposed
so in relation to both phases two which
is this residential area south of the
ditch and phase three North there are
slight changes in the affordable mix in
terms of one two three bed properties
compared to what was approved for in
those areas so in relation to phase two
we're talking about one fewer one bed
affordable
and one more two-bed
so I think we're getting one more bed
space right
um and then in relation to phase three
it's one more one bed three less two bed
and two more three bed
which I think
um
might equal out
if it doesn't equalize we're very nearly
there so in terms of the overall bad
spaces of affordable dwellings were okay
we also have a consultation response
back from our strategic housing team and
they've got no objection that's on the
addendum to the the mix of affordable
that are now proposed
[Music]
um
the additional flatted block well
actually
um there are still two flooded blocks
proposed in phase three in terms of
three-story flatted purpose-built flatty
blocks there are other flats
um in maze in that block so there was a
couple of this is very small scale isn't
it maybe I could just
zoom in slightly
so I think what what it's really
referring to is that we have this new I
suppose flatted block here that wasn't
on the layout for phase three here but
on the phase three layout for the
approved scheme we actually had two
purpose-built flatted blocks here
so actually there is no change
fundamentally in the number of buildings
which will be three story purpose-built
flatted blocks across the the site as a
whole
um and then I think going to the other
points raised initially in your
um sort of matters of concern relating
to the completion of the halt Farm
at the entrance to the site in relation
to hot Farm School
um kind of opening summer holidays
um the construction Environmental
Management plan and potential concerns
have existed from neighboring residents
in terms of like I think the dust those
sorts of matters
um and the knotweed are not matters that
we can take into account in the
consideration the acceptability of the
scheme before you tonight but there
certainly matters we can just confirm
whether compliance is being achieved in
relation to those conditions acceptably
at outside the meeting and any that we
need to investigate further we can do so
thank you
um I'm a little bit concerned about the
change in the roads from a road with a
pavement to a shared space
um is that really necessary to do that
and if that is the case is there any
provision going in for a speed
restriction within those roads because
quite often you get new Estates like
this you've got young Lads on there with
you with cars we've all been there and I
can see an accident waiting to happen so
I'm not very happy about the change of
the road
from a road with a pavement to a shared
space
can you address those questions please
try and help so if I just take you over
to there's two
um particularly
we'll just go in this North Corner first
so
we already in phase one which is the
kind of grayed out area have shared
surface streets so they're not uncommon
um they're not uncommon at this site as
approved and they are features of other
sites or other strategic
um housing land allocation sites across
the district
um there are
um limits to the extent that a shared
Surface Street
um can be provided at so it can't serve
um exceeded number of dwellings it also
here this is where the shared Surface
Street is this is meant to be kind of
like a the rural Edge if you like the
green Fringe
um and this shared Surface Street will
be designed to
the way it it surfaced
um is designed to kind of reduce vehicle
speeds there will be a raised platform
here up to it I think you can just see
it's quite small there I could zoom in
if you want me to
um but there are features like that
designed in
um to ensure that kind of vehicle speeds
are kept to A reduced speed
um and the number of dwellings this will
serve County hybrids are happy that this
will meet their their standards it's not
a through road so that also is a kind of
a measure that would hopefully reduce
speeds in that area you know it just
serves a few dwellings and there's no
Prospect of you know venturing South and
then swinging back around to Oxford Road
and things like that the same applies to
this area here where the Shad surface
would be in this Southern corner here so
certainly shared surface streets do not
function on the main through roads
through the site
um just zoom out of it
what you've got is a main looping
foreign
here and up here through this main Loop
Road this is not a shared surface you
know so the kind of main streets um
highways require to be up to the
adoptable standard with foot ways to the
minimum either side
um but in in small areas where you get
these cul-de-sac arrangements as long as
they don't serve too many properties our
highways are happy and they are
generally a feature that of sites that
we we don't object to
so it wouldn't be necessary then to put
a speed limit on it you think that would
be
taken care of by the road surface
there will be speed limit restrictions
on the site but I wouldn't be able to
tell you exactly what that would be I
think that would be for the high-ris
authority to kind of determine okay
thank you thank you Council sure thank
you just one point for Katie please you
said to council the Foster you're going
to ask about the entrance
in and out and the work could you come
back to the wall councilors when you get
an answer please thank you so it's only
because residents will ask us thank you
thank you Council birthday
thank you chairman we've got free
clarifications and two and a half
questions I'll stop the clarification uh
6.20 13
Financial contribution of 50 000 to
Essex County Council tools provision of
pedestrian costs and embrace line it
doesn't say he usually says and how many
houses have got to be built before like
if that or how many
when when would that be given to
for the um
she's looking for her paperwork
[Music]
uh what's doing that next one 14
Community lands be offered to healthcare
provider and it says on their Earth land
is not transferred to in
relation to cons
construction of a healthcare facility
it's released back released from the
transfer obligation what actually does
that mean
and
[Music]
22 I sort of remember going back good
year or so ago that there was going to
be some spaces but whereabouts will
there be for this school
because there was confusion about that
and if the clarification answer the
questions
um
I know you've gone through and counted
all the houses and the parking spaces
but is there actually any loss of
parking spaces
throughout with the change of planes and
I was a little bit concerned as with
counts the Constable about the shed
streets with pedestrians cars and
scooters
with the speed if there's gonna be a
speed limit or something on there but
you've sort of answered that question so
that was a half question
and and does the boundary Gap around the
outside of the site is that going to be
constant
between the back Gardens and
the actual site Redline
green buffer
and then my turn off questions and free
clarifications
so I was just indicating that I'd like
to ask questions afterwards okay Katie
fine thanks I'll deal with these ones
first if that's okay
um I'm just trying to find I do have a
I do have a schedule but what I can't
confirm I don't want to tell you wrong
is the 50 000 pounds and towards The
Pedestrian Crossing on Brays Lane
um there will be
um a Time
at which point that needs to be provided
um but I can get that get back to you if
that's okay because it doesn't I don't
think you know influence your decision
making tonight in relation to the
acceptability of this proposal and I
don't want to tell you the wrong thing
tonight so I will get back to you on
that to tell you when that needs to be
paid okay I'll just look at the section
106 again you also reference the land
for the healthcare facility and I think
um what you're referring to is the
backstop that's written into the section
106 agreement so what can't happen is
that
um land designated for a specific
purpose and being offered to an NHS
provider or other that offer can't be
indefinite if you like so whenever legal
Agreements are formulated there has to
be a certain point at which
um that maybe that NHS provider confirms
that they do not want that land okay
let's come back on that yeah I do know
we've um and she's County councilors and
trying to get the health provider to
actually use 106 money it usually takes
a lot longer than two years for them to
actually make any decision so I think
two years is a very short space of time
for that I think that they would run out
of time on that so what
um what we can't do tonight I don't
think because this application is just
seeking to amend elements of the
approved layout
um but what we could do is take that
comment away and you know maybe the
council can work to try to you know
um push the NHS to come but that I
suppose that is outside the decision
making that's relevant to this decision
tonight but we could take that away yeah
um and then the school places maybe I
can just point that out let me just zoom
in a little bit
so this is also
um part of the schedule of the section
106 agreement that relates to the site
and no no changes proposed to that
um at all
um
so here you can see here we've got
ashington Road and the entrance to the
site here and we've got the community
building indicated on that corner there
um got spaces here
um for potential use in relation for
that community building and it's this
area grade out here so it's part of
phase one okay and there's another
footpath link through this is just a
footpath link I think emergency vehicle
access actually as well in this area
here through touching the road but
there's this area here and then you've
got the schools on the opposite side of
the road as long as they would use a
pedestrian foot way to go through to
cross the road yeah they wouldn't need
to go on any votes other than Crossing
them they'd have to cross Ash in the
road but no they wouldn't need to cross
any road within the site because this is
just a an emergency vehicle access only
will be bollards on it yeah
um so lots of parking spaces I think
that was a question is there a loss so
then I don't have a number of parking
spaces across the whole site as a whole
but the
as a result of changes slight changes to
the dwelling mix
there might be slight changes because if
you have like one bed properties
required by your standard to have one
one space two bed plus required to have
two in some cases on the site layout
um some of the dwellings have three
because they have a garage space as well
but because the garage isn't quite the
depth
um that the the adopted parking standard
requires in order for it to be counted
as a space we haven't counted them could
still function as a parking Bay parking
space some people have smaller cars fit
in their garage no problem but we have
discounted those so they're in addition
if you like but the number of dwellings
that are proposed to the mix proposed to
the number of one two three
meets your parking standard in terms of
the the number of spaces that need to be
provided per dwelling and that's
including visitor spaces as well in
terms of visitor spaces
bear with me
all right sorry
I've just given it it's on 6.42 I think
great 6.4 page 6.42
uh yes
2.104 so
so those are still the same on it
naughty exactly the same number of
visitor spaces as was approved but still
policy compliant
thank you and then your last point Have
I Lost
oh the boundary Gap outside of the site
is it constant
so
the buffer the green buffer I think
that's what you're referring to
clarification using the minimum distance
but the constant I might just need
clarification in what you mean by the
green buffer because in lots of areas
the proposed rear Garden boundary so
let's just zoom into this area of the
site up here in the Northwest so
in this area for instance bordering
existing you have the garden boundary
there's no green buffer as such it's the
rear Garden boundary and then you've got
the dividing fence or band treatment and
then the Garden area to the property to
know so it's not a consistent green
buffer around the entire site
mostly clarification maybe what I mean
is the back garden fences will there be
a gap between them will they be putting
another fence not sharing the one that's
already there
I would
see I'm being told that there'll be new
fencing around the whole site so there
may well be an existing
um boundary treatment or it may be that
there's no boundary treatment in which
case the new fence that forms the
boundary on the site will be the only
hard boundary but if there's already a
fence there there'll be two fences are
butting each other I guess but there'll
be no there is no green buffer strip
between those two fences proposed okay
yeah thank you councilor Watson uh
thanks chairman I've got um three
questions
um I welcome that there's extra trees on
the proposed layout
um to the original
um but could ask a question about on
post 6.4 conditions eight which relates
to nesting birds and condition nine
which relates to tree protection of
trees that are in the tree and building
parameter plan and the question is have
any Hedges or trees that are in that
plan
um been removed
um our second question is I couldn't
find in the report we've changed the
layout of the green space but how does
that affect the overall area of the
Green Space
um and my third question is that from
the drawing it appears to indicate that
there are fewer trees acting as a screen
on the Northern boundary and I just like
clarification if that's correct thank
you
so the first question relating to the
condition
um that condition requires that
um
uh I can't remember which condition it
was if on if you've got it thank you
um six eight sorry
um so existing in hedgerows and trees
indicated to remain on the trees and
hedgerows and building parameter Plan
and there's a reference shall remain not
be filled or removed so as far as I
understand it
um I'm I'm not actively investigating
any complaints in relation to the breach
of that condition
um or I don't think our enforcement team
are so again I suppose in relate if
there is any concern that that hasn't
been adhered to
um we could as a council's enforcement
team look at that but um it wouldn't be
sort of
an important to decision making before
you tonight because it relates to a
condition and there's no amen proposed
to that condition it would be carried
over and still apply
um in relation to the overall area of
green space now I'm afraid I don't have
a paragraph reference but I do know that
in the report there is reference to
um the Strategic green spaces throughout
the site and how that changes
um maybe God don't if colleagues can
find that for me and rather than me sort
of um flick through but what I can say
in relation to this part which is the
the part which is changing mostly
because actually very little is changing
in relation to the East-West ditch or
the Eastern Parkland strategic Green
Space so approximately this whole area
is increasing by about 0.1 of a hectare
so it's not a huge difference I mean
it's certainly not a decrease overall
yeah oh sorry that was that one and I
think that you might have had another
Point sorry so fewer trees
um so let me actually we could stay on
actually I might just take you to that
comparison plan again
oh not that one this one
so
um I think when you say fewer trees on
the Northern boundary I think this is
the area yeah because the northern
boundary is much wider than that but a
majority of that it's rear Gardens
immediately adjacent rare Gardens
whereas here we've got some strategic
space this was the approved
um Arrangement and this is the one two
three four five and if you count that
little one I don't know if you would six
um and then you've got
um one two three four five six so
they're slightly differently positioned
but you still have trees there as you
did have on the approved scheme forming
over time I appreciate
um a buffer or some sort of screening
natural screening
um between the existing and proposed
development
these these buff color trees are feature
trees and on the landscape master plan
that's been submitted they there are
particular species that are identified
for feature trees okay but these other
trees whether they are this dark green
color and that size indicated or the
lighter green color to the smaller size
the landscape master plan indicates the
same mix of species so when we come to
discharge the conditions that relate to
um the detailed planting scheme for this
area of the site
um there is nothing to say that actually
all of these trees couldn't be the same
species yeah
um or as it could have been here okay so
they are slightly differently positioned
but we're comfortable and we would work
with them the council's agricultural
officer to make sure the right trees are
planted in the right place okay
um out of a discharge of condition phase
but we're comfortable that they'll still
be tree-lined can you just
okay sorry go back with my colleague has
found the um the reference in the in the
committee report to the
um green space in the central Northern
Area and that actually apologies I'd
said 0.1 this is referencing 0.24
hectares difference so that might have
taken into account changes to the the
whole as well
um but there's certainly no decrease
across the site
[Music]
okay members no more questions
thank you chairman
um a couple of items where
um
we have a policy of
basically peppercorn indie or pepper in
the site with affordable homes and they
seem to be accumulated in areas
or been moved to those areas which I
find difficult to uh to take it on the
basis that it we've already
been down this road of putting groups of
affordable hose together and where we
found the difficulty there
in the
original proposed plan and if you'd like
to put that one up there we've got
garages in the I think it's north
in the corner there where they've
changed the road layout there are
garages in that area from those homes
and so we're losing those garages for
another home basically
and I find that difficult to
put in contrast to what what is proposed
at the moment
there doesn't seem to be
um a dividing line
where or there is a dividing line on the
proposed where you've got affordable
homes and not spread out a little bit in
the way of
um non uh affordable homes
the other thing that
particularly worries me the attenuation
Pond
um
that is where is all that water going to
go when it fills up
and what is the what will be the outcome
to those properties
on that surrounding corner
um
and I think my last comment is to do
with
the road layer itself but that's already
been discussed
um at a previous
counselor thank you
um so in relation to the affordable
homes and the council's policy refers to
the fact that they should be spread
across the site and then Council Stanley
is correct that in Brackets then that
after spread it contains the word pepper
potting but there's no hard and fast
definition of such
um the mppf design guide talks about
well integrated homes throughout the
site it talks about a mix of properties
so yes on this site we've got affordable
and we've got a range of one two three
bed the affordable although they're all
shown with red dots at the moment on the
plan there will be a mix of both
affordable rented properties an
affordable shared ownership properties
so there's also that that mix as well
which is not shown highlighted on this
particular plan that just indicates all
with red dots and the changes
um I do have a plan maybe I'll show you
that it is not a plan that's been
submitted for approval but it is a plan
that we have just for our own sort of
um consideration
um
of the scheme in relation to looking at
the the spread if you like let me just
explain this for clarity so this is not
a plan for approval and these yellow
dots
um sometimes
um are over whole blocks of flats okay
so they don't indicate number so don't
count them and then you know compare the
number of yellow dots what these plans
are in intended to do is give you a a
sort of visual indication of the spread
of affordable across the site from
proposed on the right hand side to
approved on the left hand side and and
the gray the grayed out area and the
slightly kind of um lighter colored
yellow dots within that grayed out area
a phase one affordable and although
they're not shown on this approved
scheme they're exactly the same okay so
when you're looking at that don't think
that there's more affordable than than
the proof there isn't there is um that
these are equally should be shown on
here okay so keep that in mind in
relation to then the proposed in phase
two okay so you still have these two
individual not individual plots because
I think they relate to a flatted block
here an amazing that block here but
they're exactly the same no change
again these two here are these two here
no change
what we we regard this as like a cluster
um and we think we would say that this
is still a cluster in the same general
location so yes there is a tweak to the
positioning so this semi-detached here
that was approved now flips over to here
but what you still got in this street is
a mix of affordable properties and open
market properties on the same side of
the street but also opposite the street
as well and then on this southern
boundary
um you had a row of affordable I think
there were so many attached but that
might not all be and then you had one
detached open market house on the end
that's changed slightly and the open
market house is now here
um but again you've got a street which
is
mixed and we say well integrated because
you've got
um affordable on one side but straight
opposites and Market housing here
um and then in the phase three area
again these two here are consistent so
no change
um in this area here essentially this
one here that was approved
um sorry this this is this is consistent
these three here
um and you've just got a minor change to
this this area here
um which is this area here
this area east of the Green Space was
always this cluster of affordable so
they were two flooded blocks and then
um some rows of terraces and you've
still got the one flatted block and the
maisonet surrounding and then in this
North Western area there are some
changes to the plots but we still say
there's a general mix of open market
plus affordable and so there are
differences but we say it's not Material
um to Warrant any concerns that the
scheme wouldn't be appropriately well
integrated in terms of the different
types of Housing and then bear in mind
my comment that some of these yellow
dots will be properties that are shared
ownership properties
um that's just a different affordable
product
um in relation to
the attenuation pond
so the surface water that's falling on
the residential Parcels will all be
directed to a piped surface water
drainage Network which will outfall to
these attenuation basins which have been
appropriately sized the llfa are
comfortable but they're adequately sized
to deal with the number of dwellings and
that the site serves and they will out
fall off site to the public water sewer
so there'll be no risk of
um over topping of those attenuation
basins of anything to result in any kind
of increased flood risk to those
dwellings surrounding the site either
existing or proposed
um and then the garages
on the Northern I'm not quite Maybe
I think you might need to direct me if
possible to is on the approved plan
we're talking about the garages on the
approved okay just bear with me a second
yep
foreign
just trying to find
it too oh was it on that one apologies
this is the phase this is the full
approved site layout so is it on this
one
on the Northern
I'm just I don't know quite where garage
is
where the pH is with the p is that if
you go to the left of that there was two
garages in the on the parceland with the
detached properties
ah okay yeah
let me just zoom in a little bit to this
area are we talking about this site this
no further over
okay West
over here
let's zoom in a little bit
then they've been taken out so this is
the approved layout
um can we pinpoint what so these are
garages so there's a garage here there's
garages here that would serve these
detached properties and that's the
garage at the back so all the garages
are sort of sighted rearward
this is proposed oh sorry this is this
is approved yeah and on the yeah
so on this proposed layout this part of
the site is proposed to change
um there are still some detached
dwellings that will have garages
these are not garages these are just
parking Bays
these are just two parking Bays side by
side if you like but some of the
properties still feature garages these
ones here step back into the rear Garden
I think that was all
you wish can I just come back with um
the the flats obviously would be I would
have thought that there'd be one bed two
bed and affordable uh flat top ropes on
those Flats in the far corner on that
Crescent right in the center there
um I I there's no change on that at all
but my point is that opposite you've got
affordable homes just the same and to
the right of that you've got another row
of all you know there's no breakup as as
to what we had imagined there would be
in the way of breaking up those
properties where you've got blocks of
four you've got two blocks of floor if
you was to separate those
and put something in the middle of those
that would then give a little bit more
of a spread to those affordable homes
and to in other words integrated into
the master plan that's what I'm saying
chairman you've already made this point
we've already been asked and answered
yeah I think that has been answered
if I'm right can you confirm yeah I mean
I'm just going to say is the area here
that you're concerned about cancer
Stanley this area here because this area
here
um although we have a different
um layout
um and different there's still this
flatted block here but this was another
Flathead block and then we had some
Terraces but this area was all
affordable on the approved scheme and
continues to be so yes it's a different
layout of houses but um
yeah
okay members any more questions
no okay the recommendation is to approve
the application subject to conditions
and hits a terms set out on pages 6.1 to
6.2 of the two one of the report and the
revised conditions set out on pages one
and two of the addendum I am going to
propose that from the chair do I have a
second up
cancer rifty thank you those in favor
please indicate
okay hands down thank you those against
and any abstentions
thank you that application is approved
thank you members moving on to
item agenda items seven
[Music]
number 14 ashington Heights Claire
Buckley will present the officer report
thank you
this application is for a single story
extension to an existing detached garage
to form a subroom and to use the
remaining garage for storage it is
before members for consideration as the
applicant is a member of staff I
approxford District Council as you can
see from the location plan the area
outlined in Reading just going over it
as well just having to identify it the
site is located within the residential
area of Rochford surrounded by dwellings
can too please Katie thank you
the site comprises a detached running
house an adjacent picture of detached
garage which sits back from the highway
and is located on the boundary of number
12. so this is the existing region here
so you've got the dwelling here and then
the detached garage located there set
back from the from the front um there so
it's got a driveway area to the front
The Proposal seeks an extension to the
existing garage with a pitch through to
a height of some 3.8 meters projecting
towards the rear of the site the
extension would form a sunroom with the
existing garage element being used for
storage
the extension would follow the existing
boundary line retaining a slight
separation to the boundary of
approximately 0.2 meters the width
proposes some 2.8 meters with roof
featuring two roof lights facing south
and a set of bi-folding doors to the
southern elevation as its fenestration
the garage door to the existing garage
would remain so just to identify here so
existing garage so it would extend to
the rear there like that to form a
sunroom and you can see on this um here
that's where the roof lights will be
located facing inwards towards their
Garden area along with some bifolding
doors and you can see here the proximity
to the neighbor here
so the key material planning
considerations are impact on the
character of the area residential
ability Garden size parking ecology and
trees
so looking at impact on the character of
the area The Proposal is considered to
positively contribute to the existing
dwelling by way of external finishes and
is of appropriate scale maths and design
I would not give rise to a detrimental
impact on the character the application
sites nor would it be detrimental to the
appearance of the street scene
with residential amenity the nearest
neighbor is located at number 12. it is
not considered the proposed extension
would be any more imposing than the
relationship with an existing garage at
number 12 has the West so that's in
reference to there's an existing garage
that we're located here so the rear
boundary of number 12 is along here and
they already have a garage
um in an enabling plot located to the
rear here
it is not considered that the proposal
will be detrimental to the residential
amenity of any other neighboring
properties
Garden size sufficient Garden area would
remain with a proposal in place in
accordance with our supplementary
guidance
looking at parking the original 1997
application at this site had a planning
conditioning post that required the
garage to be retained for the parking of
vehicles only
however the existing garage does not
comply with the current length of garage
space required within the parking
standards guidance and is therefore not
considered to form a usable parking
space for consideration the existing
driveway area provides suitable parking
at the site and is considered acceptable
so you can see and just in the top right
hand corner here
um this is where the driveway spaces are
located here and they considered
acceptable
ecology entries the bat survey
declaration form submitted indicates
that there is not likely to be harmed to
backs or their habitat as a result of
the proposed Works only minor trees and
hedges within the Garden area would
require removal this application is
recommended for approval chairman
subject to the conditions outlined in
the offices report
[Music]
thank you Claire uh members questions
yeah good evening
um I noticed the report the reason is
here is because the actual applications
for a member of Brookshire District
Council
the question is if it was a member of
the public that applied for this would
it already received planning permission
and because I noticed there's no
objections from any Parish councils or
any of the neighbors so my suggestion
would be
would be put it straight to a vote
because we've already chance to read the
papers and if it was a member of the
public it would have been granted I'm
second that chairman
hang on a minute councilor Foster would
like to speak please
yeah thank you Tim just a quick Point
really it's a question
um I understand that it's out of scope
of the
planning department but the items are
made raised on page 7.6 items 3.1 and
3.2 is there any way it can be ensured
that these matters were addressed
outside of the planning
One Clip
[Music]
so which were the paragraph numbers
again please sorry looking at page 7.6
ice Paris 3.1 and 3.2
you raises some issues which are
out of scope in terms of this but
probably for the neighbors need to be
addressed is there any way they can
ensure they're addressed and they
couldn't be addressed as part of the
planning application process they would
be private matters they'd have to
address between independent parties
themselves
and in answer to the other query I think
that was raised um yes if it was a
member of the public that wasn't a
member of staff at Watford if they had
submitted this application we would have
proceeded with um our delegation as
officers to issue an approval for this
application
[Music]
counselors down here are you indicating
yes I did thank you chairman
um one thing that does
looking at the plans and whatever can we
put any condition on the tree planting I
notice there is only now one tree that's
on that scale I don't know if we can put
a condition of putting the tree back
maybe not
I think with this scale of application
it would be
um it wouldn't be a reasonable part of
this application although obviously it
is Justified on quite a large scale
development schemes for this level of
scheme it's we're not losing a
substantial train anyway it's only
modest
um things in the way Garden
okay thank you no more questions
okay the recommendation is to approve
the application subject to condition set
out on pages 7.1 to 7.2 of the report I
note that councilor Myers has proposed
this do I have a second councilor Lawman
thank you all those in favor please
indicate
that is unanimous thank you very much
members and at
uh
uh 42 minutes past eight the meeting is
closed
thank you very much for your attendance
and for your participation
can I also say a special thank you to
our officers I think have done a
sterling job tonight thank you